I get a burning sensation sometimes where I had radiation in the past after my left breast mastectomy nearly four years ago.
What would be the causes of this and what could I do to prevent it?
So a burning sensation anywhere in your body can be a side of something going on.
So that can be cells reproducing to heal the area.
If it's where you had post surgery, where you had radiation, it's a concern.
Of course, it is because you can get cancer coming back at an area where you had cancer before.
Certainly you could get a totally different type of cancer where you had radiation.
That's what I don't like about soft tissue radiation.
There's plenty of data that shows the higher incidence of melanomas where there was radiation for breast cancer or other cancers.
So yeah, it's a concern.
It's something that if you're still getting regular checkups with an oncologist getting a PET scan might be appropriate.
Can be just the tissue healing can be just scar formation too, so I don't want to raise too much concern when it's not necessary.
But it's something to be aware of.
Certainly, when you have scar formation from an injury in the past, you can get that type of feeling.
Even if it's like you cut yourself really bad, you had stitches done, you could get a birdie or a tingle or a weird sensation where that was done.
It's just scar formation.
So, I don't want to raise too much concern, but you always want to, you know, suspect possibilities.
What can you do for it? You wouldn't do, put anything out there that would increase replication.
But I would certainly think some different herbal saves could be beneficial.
I think coledula saves would be a good idea for that. I don't know that I would use company.
I use coledula saves might be a good idea, even just some coconut oil could be good to go over scar over where you had radiation could be help.
It could be healing and prevent further scar formation.